you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles in each of them
it's white to play and it's up to you to
determine the best continuation so go
ahead and pause the video see if you can
find the best play for white ok the
solution the puzzle one is to first
remove the defender of f7 namely Queen
takes Knight and after rook takes Queen
which is the only move pawn takes pawn
and after King 7 which is once again the
only move we have checkmate with Bishop
before and this is turning out to be a
checkmate three puzzle and is one which
can maybe be best found by looking into
what moves white can make which will
limit black's replies the most Queen
takes Knight pawn takes pawn both of
those will limit blacks replies greatly
they will force only replies by black
however in this case Queen takes Knight
will eventually lead to the best
continuation moving on to the second
puzzle light to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation ok
the solution to this one is to first
give Czech Queen takes is the only move
another check Queen takes is the only
move after pawn takes King to g8 another
only move and now we give checkmate with
97 this was turning out to be a
checkmate in 4 puzzle and following a
similar train of thought as puzzle 1
with going with the moves which will
limit blacks replies the most I believe
that will lead you in the right
direction with this one moving on to the
third white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation ok
the solution to this one is Queen takes
a7 and I do believe that it may have
been tempting to play 95 trying to
exploit the pin on this rook on f8 but
what is most forceful is Queen takes and
now after a check King b8 what do you do
now you throw one more piece into the
mix Knight b6 which is exploiting the
pin on this pond there is no pawn takes
Knight and there is no successful
defense against this rook coming to a8
which will deliver me so this is
certainly a move which is bit difficult
to see these quiet moves
but what's something that can maybe
allow you to see a move like that is
knowing that if you are to get into this
position here the king recognized how
limited he is with his moves he is kind
of stuck right he can't go to a door a
seven he certainly should not go to c8
because of me and if he could somehow
manage to get that rip to AAA it'll turn
out to be made soon enough Knight b6
will do the trick
in this case moving on to the fourth one
white to play pause the video see if you
can find the best play okay solution to
this one rook e8
there is only one reply Queen a2 there's
only one reply and now Queen a7
interesting move to see if king c8 will
deliver made on a and if she has taken
now we allow for a fourth move which
will produce a double check well tonight
and Bishop rating the king and
regardless of where he plays a or a six
let's just say he runs to a6 rook to a-1
and that's going to be main this was
turning out to be a checkmate in five
puzzle but again pretty much all moves
by white we're limiting black in a great
way moving on now to the fifth and final
white to play pause the video so you can
find the best play okay solution to this
one is g5 and before I go any further do
know that if you first played Queen h7 I
would also give you full credit for that
or you could give yourself full credit
for that the idea here is to have this
g5 and Queen h7 idea in mind let's go
with g5 first attacking the bishop and
if the bishop is to move let's say
grabbing the pun now threatening mate on
b2 this is what would follow Queen check
King f8 and now Queen h8 the other key
move to have seen after Bishop takes
Queen which is an only move we grab the
bishop and after King g7 which turns out
to now be an only move we get this other
rook involved on the H file and there's
no successful defense against rook 1 to
H 7 which would deliver me this pawn is
conveniently there to watch out for that
escape square f6
so as it turns out in this puzzle right
here after the bishop is threatened with
g5 it's probably best that the bishop
not move but if it doesn't move you're
at least winning some material and as a
result the game keep in mind white
already from this position is up the
exchange and I guess as a last bonus
type of question what position or what
opening was this how did how did this
position come about from which opening
and variation if you'd like to pause the
video and I'll just go ahead and give
you the solution to it okay those of you
who guess that it's the Sicilian defense
the dragon variation you are correct and
even follow-up there must have been
I believe so at some point a sacrifice
on this c3 square a typical sacrifice to
try and exploit the queenside castle
position of the white king but
nevertheless the solution to this puzzle
was this either g5 or queen h7 that is
the right idea with Queen h8 to follow
so that's all for this video as always
let me know how you did in the comments
section below and I'll catch you in the
next video take care bye
you